what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to some
fresh and fit
podcasts a fresh and i don't know i
guess it's a
show podcast whatever clips um
this one is called strong independent
woman turns feeble after
man breaks in they mean to like
the show i don't know before i start do
not forget to like comment
and subscribe hit that subscribe button
what do they say ring the bell
for notifications i don't know okay
i try to be quick
that's what you consider a high-valued
woman a high-value woman is a woman who
was right or died that's what the whole
thing's about since the dawn of time
high by a woman is this
me and you are walking down the street
together some guy tries to take her
handbag i smash him in the face
i get i catch a murder charge because i
punch like that right
and this is a true story she stays with
you and she's in the jail cell
she's there seeing me every weekend for
seven years she ain't touching another
dude
let me tell you something most what most
most of what you girls are talking about
i'm horny
i'll go [ __ ] this guy blah blah this
[ __ ] why am i gonna catch a murder
charge for a chick
who's gonna go [ __ ] another guy while
i'm in a jail cell to protect her life
why are you doing that if this man
has too much energy for me what is
everything gotta be extremes
if i'm with a chick it's for real maybe
maybe i'm just
old now right i ain't playing games with
chicks unless i truly believe there's a
chance
we're gonna be forever for real and when
for real means
i might catch a charge i'm that guy
right i might do it
if you're if you can't look at your
woman and know with certainty
she will wait for you as long as it
takes what the [ __ ] you buying dinner
for
this is true so you're talking about
[ __ ] this dude and we're equal and
i'll run here and [ __ ] this guy
but all love is conditional i mean okay
if he punches someone in the face trying
to protect you catches the murder charge
whatever that's one situation
but you never know if something's gonna
be forever
everything's conditioned last thing in a
million years i'm going to entertain in
a million years
you'll still cheat on her though it
doesn't listen you got to think about
what you say with an open mind
it's not cheating it's genuinely not and
you know what if i had a woman who was
truly for me i wouldn't even be
chasing other girls i'm not even saying
i would do it you guys are thinking i'm
out here saying if i have a girl on a
tutor every week
i'm not saying that my point is this if
i did
if i did it would be in no way
comparable
to a female having sex with another man
in no way comparable it wouldn't be on
the same
page it would be a completely separate
event it wouldn't even be comparable the
different they're different things
and this is where i think feminists get
angry and it even like makes my blood
boil a little bit because he's expecting
this extreme loyalty from a woman
and not willing to put in the same thing
like i know men and women sex is
different
but at the end of the day you should
respect who you're with
and it doesn't even sound like he's
saying he would cheat but
i got a question for the ladies right
now i got a question for the ladies okay
so um guys uh so let's pretend right
let's go into a dream world okay
all right dream world okay i take you on
a first date
right and let's say that you know i'm
not exactly your type but good enough
for a first date right
so you show up on the first date i got a
helicopter there i give you some flowers
we go and do you know do a tour in miami
look you know go fly over the city and
everything else like that
then i say hey i got uh reservations for
nurseret right for some of you guys that
don't know that's salt based restaurant
right thousand dollar steaks and all
that [ __ ]
we go over there we get some steak then
i take you shopping
spend you spend ten thousand dollars etc
um and this is the first day you don't
know me
you know who's dropping 10k on a first
date
that i have never had that treat and
i've done all the uh all this stuff for
you
but how would you uh like how how did
you feel
no you feel good okay but real talk
would you [ __ ] me that night
probably yes yeah
are we prostitutes now it all depends if
you like the woman sex shouldn't be
expected just because you put money down
that's not fair to throw money at a
woman and just expect her to have sex
with you
depends on how you don't have to you
don't have to but i know the point
myron's making yeah
i've had guys that have taken me to
expensive restaurants that i didn't vibe
with and i did not [ __ ] and i've had
guys that have taken me to cheap
restaurants that i did
with that okay the point of the matter
is you know what thank you for saying
that
so how why did you not [ __ ] those guys
that took you to those nice places and
spent all that money on because they
were weird and awkward and just
like i didn't like my emotional
connection with them was not enough
okay translation for the woman east she
did not respect them
right because the guy went ahead and
gave his resources for free for no
goddamn reason
he doesn't know he had no songs exactly
so
ladies so if i take you on a crazy date
like that spend all those money
and spend all that money yeah but the
thing is is that nine out of 10 times a
guy that spent does the most on a first
date like that
that you barely know you're not going to
respect him you're not going to [ __ ]
you're not going to want to [ __ ] him
you're not going
because it feels cheap like you don't
even know me at all
and you're willing to throw out that
throw down this amount of money
it seems like you'll just do that for
everyone and no girl wants to feel like
she's just
one of many you're rise by him et cetera
unless he has
okay well yeah but if he had a sauce
he'd take you somewhere cheap
he wouldn't need it he wouldn't need a
helicopter he wouldn't need to do all
that extra [ __ ] so the point is this
ladies
you guys could say on paper oh i want a
guy to bring me flowers all this other
[ __ ] no it doesn't work
because nice guys finish last for a
reason they finished last because
women don't respect them women only [ __ ]
guys that they respect first
so that that's what it's got to be so
with that said if i part ways with my
resources time and attention
for free right by taking on these
exclusive first dates and you don't even
[ __ ] know me
you're not going to take me seriously
that's exactly how men feel about women
that give sex away easily
you know what i'm saying because i have
to give you guys an example you go on a
first date with a guy who shows you all
this extra [ __ ] you're like
hmm this is fun but i'm not gonna [ __ ]
this guy as a matter of fact you know
what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna make him take me out on three
or four or five dates yup so i can
continue to get free things and see i
see some of the girls here laughing
because you've all been on dates with
men that you had zero intention of
[ __ ] but you went out with them
but it's not worth your time oh my gosh
i will not when i was dating i would not
go on
multiple dates with a guy that i have no
interest in
like it's true correct that's exactly
how men feel
about women that give sex away very
quickly like that and i hate to say it
like that but
i have to give you guys a comparison
because you guys think it's apples it's
apples and apples no no no it's apples
and oranges
what about guys i'll give sex away
quickly okay
men don't give us two different
parallels
oh my goodness we're different we're
different in every regard i i don't know
how else to explain this
because the idea is that men have to
work for sex women don't so it's easy
for women to give sex
different in every regard why are we not
equal why are we not equal i'll tell you
why we're not equal biologically we're
not equal
you can have children i can fight right
we're different
do you agree that we're biologically
different or do you think you're as
strong as men
no of course not okay there you go then
so there we go so we already have a
biological
you're the protector and i'm like the
british no we have a biological
difference and if you have a certain
biology wouldn't you agree that your
biology lends to your mentality
right okay so we have a different
biology and a different mentality do you
agree
yeah okay so we're not equal stop
that's true i don't disagree with any of
that men and women aren't equal
i have a question um
for the men what do you guys consider a
high-valued man is it
looks is it money or is it both or i
mean what's your opinion on that i'm
just curious on what you guys as a man
thinks a high value man is
you want to go first ceo or me yeah you
can go first you know what i truly think
a high value man is mm-hmm
a high-value man is doing something
which nearly okay it's a few things
right so there's the obvious
evolutionary triggers the easiest way to
be a high-value man is a man who's
capable of violence
we look at it from a biological trigger
it doesn't matter if he's got muscles or
he's big or he's tall whatever
women understand from a biological
perspective they like a man who can
fight
yeah it doesn't matter if your man had
money a ferrari everything but if you
knew for a fact
if any dude stepped to him he'd get
sparked you wouldn't want him right so
that's the first thing
no but no yeah you need a mannequin
fight but but really truly to answer
your question i think the the true value
of a high
the true marker of a high value man is a
man who could say no to [ __ ]
and i mean this on a genuine level
here's the problem here's the problem
you girls don't understand
all the lower level dudes you say i
don't want a high value man who cheats
da da
if you got a lower value guy he'll cheat
with anybody
he'll [ __ ] anything period he has no
choice
if you get a high value guy at least he
has the option to say no to something
wait who's his [ __ ]
yeah but okay i don't know what they're
doing right now i think it's about to
get intense but
i'm gonna give you my two cents i'm
gonna do it um
you guys real one guns are the great
equalizer you don't need to have to
fight if you know how to use a gun
point in case uh second thing
i forgot what i was gonna say okay
that's it you're saying
is he saying my name i don't know who
this guy is
i don't give a [ __ ] we're doing a
[ __ ] podcast my friend get out of
here
chris yeah get the [ __ ] out of here
how did he get in here
i don't know [ __ ] weirdo he's trying
to fight you
he's trying to fight you i don't know he
ain't trying to fight me so i say hello
to me
he's trying to fight your fight oh it's
not a fight i just want the [ __ ]
he wants i thought he just said he's
trying to fight
is
this is such click bait i couldn't even
see i want to see the 500
coin it's at eight grand right now guys
there are probably more
yo who is that follow me on instagram
y-i-t-s-i-t-a-s-o oh
follow me champagne pocky like drake but
with
[ __ ] the giants there's a world of
smoke
at all i took my jacket off on a
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] he's like oh
this is an interesting psychology like
fact or not even fact just like
body language read he seems in the
middle
very confident the i don't know his name
but the other co-host that sits over
here very confident
his vibe like i feel he seems like
he feels like less of a man when he's
like next to those two i don't know why
just a vibe literally who
who the hell bro wait how did he find
how did he find us
wait um yeah
what happened just now what's some scary
[ __ ]
i'm gonna take my watch off okay so i
have to change my mind nobody's gonna
tell me what happened
this [ __ ] happens you know what happened
so this guy was his fan right
he was like hey i'm trying to suck you
that's crazy how did he find the room
okay i think they're done um okay that
fight
took a turn i was like what i didn't
even get to see the fight that was such
a click bait why would they do that to
me the end was so boring
guys i got a haircut and i'm so bummed
they took off way too much of my hair
but let me know in the comments what you
guys think
do you agree or do you disagree don't
forget to like comment and subscribe
i'll talk to you guys next time